enough already
you walk into the Sunsplash olives mossy
trunks greener than fresh grass this
doesn't seem to be enough so you think
even here they grow olives only young
warm terraces and ask who first found
that olives had to be cured
this cleverness to does not sense so
walking hand in hand into the Grove you
say the world needs us and other lovers
to give such life which would do nicely
for most save those who leave it for a
creator but then alone you look real
close in the black spot on the green
bark you reach for sharpens in two inch
and a half of scorpion and you see a red
beetle and by God that does device it's
done there isn't too much science at all
yes it is it is limited because some of
the sort of poetry in sciences dependent
on being part of the cognitive framework
of knowing what went before what it's
about the part of it is what I find
inspiring is the the
language kind of natural languages
scientists speak and they don't think
the language is important they think
equations and chemical formulas
important the language is all we've got
this language is made to serve to
express things so words like energy and
force mean special things well they
fight we tried to make them fit and then
there are words invented in words used
let me give you an example what often
happens to me is it's given to me to go
to dull seminars and sometimes after I
fall asleep I wake up and still going up
and so I listen sometimes to the words
even expect what's so interesting and if
someone came at a seminar I was talking
about some mathematical equation he said
let us assume three boundary conditions
he was talking about some technical
words boundary conditions are what you
do on a mathematical equation to make it
fit at the ends but so the idea three
boundaries was very interesting because
it was a typical Zen idea of something
being free and something being
constrained so I worked that into a poem
so the language is interesting